it's been close to six months since
apple announced max safe and their
iphone 12 lineup
and now there's a large variety of
different third-party mac save
accessories available to purchase
including both affordable versions of
apple's accessories
and brand new ones that apple has yet to
release we already made a video talking
about the best mac save accessories a
couple months after its launch
so if you haven't seen it yet make sure
to check that out but in this video i
want to talk about some of the brand new
mac save accessories that we think
are well worth buying let's start off
with the most simple one
a lot of people love using pop sockets
and rings with their phones to have
better grip
and as a kickstand for watching videos
but if you use one
you can no longer have access to magsafe
in october we had info that popsockets
were working on a mac saved version of
their product
however for some reason they have yet to
finish and release it fortunately we
found a third party base which allows
you to use a pop socket or ring
while still being able to easily remove
it and use other magsafe accessories
by the way we have all of these mac save
accessories linked down below
along with a couple other ones that we
would recommend now moving on to the
next accessory
we have something we've been waiting a
long time for magsafe powerbank a
portable charger is one of the most used
and most essential phone accessories to
exist now this maxi fund brings it to a
whole nother level
you no longer need to have a cable with
you and have to carry it all together
nonetheless walking around holding it
while your phone is charging which is
something that i've had to do
a lot with this max save charger you
don't need a cable since your phone
charges wirelessly
you just snap the bank to the back of
your phone and that's it it's easy to
carry around and you don't have to worry
about it falling off
this power bank we found costs 30 bucks
which is a steal
currently apple sells a smart battery
case for the 11's for 130 bucks they're
not very convenient because they're
designed to stay on your phone
which makes your phone thick and they're
not quick and easy to remove
apple will likely eventually release
their own mac safe battery packs
but based on the price of that case it's
going to be extremely expensive
definitely over a hundred dollars and
possibly even up to 150. so for 30 bucks
this power bank is an amazing deal
it has 5000 milliamp hours of capacity
and has usbc to charge up
the only downside is how fast it charges
up your phone but since you can easily
use your phone while you have it
attached
charging time is not a big deal there's
also the sleek looking anchor one for 10
bucks more which has basically the same
specs
but it's out of stock so we couldn't get
our hands on it now let's move on to
something i'm really excited about
and it's this mac safe wall mount for 15
bucks you basically just take the
magnetic pad anywhere you want and
you're set
it also comes with a magnetic ring to
use with non iphone 12s
there are so many places you can put
this for convenience my favorite is in
the kitchen because then you can just
have it on the wall have a recipe open
and you don't have to lift it up or bend
down to look at it you can have it
mounted and play videos as well
you can also use this as a car mount on
your dash it's super small and sleek and
a better alternative to using a vent
mount
since the constant blowing air can
overheat your phone in the winter and to
avoid that you need to close off the
vent entirely
which is not optimal you can also stick
this up in the bathroom to hold your
phone when brushing your teeth or
showering
and you can use this mount to
magnetically hold your keys if you like
it's extremely versatile hey guys this
is my new mac safe wall plate and it's
actually really cool
for doing vlog style videos like this so
definitely check it out
now let's move on to a few alternatives
to expensive name brand accessories
some of which are more worth it for less
let's start with the moft wallet for
about 30 bucks
previously it was only available on
muff's website but has since been added
to amazon
this is an alternative option to apple's
max safe wallet
which max now absolutely loves this
wallet is super slim
looks very classy and high quality and
has a lot of features that apples
doesn't this wallet is built in a way
where you can use it as a stand as well
and in multiple positions you can stand
it up in portrait mode
landscape mode and even in float mode
this wallet
like apples can fit three cards and the
wallet folds flat to hide the cards so
they're invisible but unlike apples this
wallet is made from faux leather
which a lot of people may actually
prefer the only downside is it might
wear down quicker than real leather
and won't build up the patina but not
everyone likes that this and apples have
the same amount of magnetism
of course even apples isn't perfect it
can slide and slip off especially if you
own a 12 pro max
but with that said it doesn't matter
since they're both the same and you're
not gaining anything more with apples
in fact with this wall being 35 bucks
you're saving 25 bucks
and getting more functionality with it
now moving on to a 3-1 stand we found
for 50 bucks
this one's very similar to belkin's 3-1
stand that you can get from apple's
website for 140 bucks
that other than the price we absolutely
love this three-in-one is awesome
because for that low price
not only do you get the stand itself but
it also comes with a power brick
cable and apple watch charger unlike
many of the three in one chargers on the
market where you have to provide your
own
this thing also has a really cool led
light on the bottom which briefly glows
to indicate that charging is started
but what's really cool about it is that
it has a touch sensitive button on the
base
that can be used to adjust brightness
now this stand claims to charge at 15
watts
however that's impossible because all
three of these chargers have to share
the same power brick
so the wattage is split up among them
but with that said no third party max
save charger can deliver full 15 watts
anyway
because apple made sure to only let
their devices accept 15 watt wireless
charging from their own approved
accessories however this isn't a big
deal for two reasons
first you're not always getting the full
15 watts even with apple's on max safe
charger and 20 watt break we did a video
testing out a bunch of different
charging methods and seeing how they
compare
and we saw that apple's max safe only
charged at 15 watts until about 20
percent
after that it gradually lowers the
wattage itself and then after about
halfway
it only charges closer to 6 watts if
you're interested in knowing more
check out that video right over there
max did a ton of testing and it took a
lot of time and work but getting back to
the stand it's mainly for night time
charging when you're asleep
so it doesn't really matter how fast or
so it charges keep all of that in mind
when shopping for any mac save charger
in the future
the last accessory is super exciting
it's a copy of apple's mac safe duo
charger that costs 130 bucks
this dupe is basically exactly the same
for only 35
this thing is great because just like
apples it's super compact and one side
can charge your apple watch while the
other
your phone or airpods and it's maxif
compatible so your phone will snap to it
and you don't have to worry about it
being bumped off and stopped charging
however the power brick is not included
it only comes with a usbc cable
so you'll need to use your own power
brick but guess what
apple's 130 duo also doesn't come with
one
which is insane and what's even worse is
if you buy the 19.20 watt
your phone will only charge at up to 11
watts not 15
because there's not enough power for the
apple watch portion and even if you have
a 27 watt or higher adapter
you weirdly only get up to 14 watt max
safe charging the beauty of this one
though is that it's usb-c
so if you travel with an ipad or macbook
you'll already have a breaking usbc
cable so you don't need to keep an extra
lightning cable to power the duo since
it uses lightning
this charger is completely different
from the three in one since with that
it's meant to be used in one location
most likely on your nightstand for
charging at night you can't really take
it anywhere since it's so bulky and too
weird of a shape to easily pack with you
this duo charger on the other hand
folds together into a tiny compact
little charger that you can take
wherever you go
and like apples there's no way that we
would pay a hundred and thirty dollars
for it
especially if you want both this
portable charger and the three one for
use in your home by the way if you buy
both the duo charger and the three in
one that's 90 bucks total
still way under how much you would pay
for just one name brand so those are our
top six
new mac save accessories that we
recommend for iphone 12 owners
and we have links to all of them down in
the description below we also have nine
more that we covered a few months ago
that are also very convenient and budget
friendly
like a car vent mount that can also
charge your phone which max has been
using for months and loves
so click right over there to check out
all nine of the accessories we covered
and click the button above to subscribe
to see more videos like this one this
has been angelica
and we'll see you in the next one
you